in this lecture we will deal with a
single topic how to find the
distribution that is the PMF or PDF of a
random variable that is defined as a
function of one or more other random
variables with known distributions why
is this useful quite often we construct
the model by first defining some basic
random variables these random variables
usually have simple distributions and
often they are independent but we may be
interested in the distribution of some
more complicated random variables that
are defined in terms of our basic random
variables in this lecture we will
develop systematic methods for the task
at hand after going through a warm-up
the case of discrete random variables we
will see that there is a general very
systematic two-step procedure that
relies on cumulative distribution
functions we will pay special attention
to the easier case where we have a
linear function of a single random
variable we will also see that when the
function involved is monotonic we can
bypass CDF and jump directly to a
formula that is easy to apply we will
also see an example involving a function
of two random variables in such examples
the calculations may be more complicated
but the basic approach based on CDF is
really the same let me close with a
final comment finding the distribution
of a function G of X is indeed possible
but we should only do it when we really
need it if all we care about is the
expected value of G of X we can just use
the expected value roll